hablar de fútbol femenino y a centrarnos
en esas elecciones latinoamericanas que
están clasificadas al Mundial de
Australia y de Nueva Zelanda este año
Así es ese gran evento que tiene el
fútbol femenino este año en tierra
oceánicas Brasil Argentina Colombia
Panamá y Costa Rica son los
representantes de la región para esta
cita que comienza ya el próximo 20 de
Julio para hablar de cómo está el
balompié de las mujeres en estos países
conectamos con la periodista Natalia
prietos directora de fémina fútbol y una
de las mayores expertas que tiene el
fútbol femenino en Colombia Natalia
primero que todo gracias por estar con
nosotros y mirando estas cinco
selecciones a priori podemos decir que
Argentina Brasil y Colombia han
consolidado sus ligas son torneos
profesionales cual es la realidad de las
jugadoras de esos países
justamente porque tenemos varias
selecciones de nuestra región que van a
participar en el mundial femenino que se
aproxima que va a ser en Australia en
Nueva Zelanda tenemos desde Sudamérica a
selecciones como Argentina Brasil y
Colombia son selecciones que han venido
trabajando como tú bien lo dices desde
la profesionalización y la evolución y
el desarrollo del fútbol jugado por
mujeres
en Argentina por ejemplo
la liga como tal o los torneos de fútbol
femenino iniciaron en el 91 cuando FIFA
prácticamente da el aval y conmebol
empieza a hacer torneos aquí en
Sudamérica En ese entonces torneo
sudamericano femenino ahora conocido
como la Copa América y Argentina Inicia
con algunos equipos como River como boca
como San Lorenzo y de ahí en adelante
hasta hace aproximadamente tres años
empieza como tal la transformación a la
profesionalización de este país claro
equipos como Boca Juniors por ejemplo
que es el equipo con más títulos en
Argentina tiene tiene aproximadamente 23
si contamos desde el 91 hasta ahora
entonces en Argentina hay un proceso
largo hay un proceso con todo lo
relacionado con el fútbol jugado por
mujeres Pero también es importante
destacar en no solamente en Argentina
sino también en Brasil y Colombia como
hoy por hoy nuestro continente exportan
jugadoras a Europa no y hoy Gracias al
nivel y el talento que se está viendo en
Sudamérica hay jugadoras en el Real
Madrid hay jugadoras de relevante y
jugadoras en Barcelona y en otros
equipos de otras ligas importantes de
ese continente
ya para hablando de Brasil Que Brasil es
una selección que ha participado de
todos los mundiales desde el primero que
inició en el noventa y uno hasta la
fecha y que prácticamente ha ganado
todas las copas Américas excepto la del
2006 que la ganó Argentina este país
tiene una liga profesional y de hecho
tiene diferentes torneos no
que es el torneo que clasifica Copa
Libertadores pero también hacen unos
torneos regionales es decir que
constantemente este país está en
movimiento está en competencia y que
gran parte de las jugadoras vivimos casi
el 80% están en en ligas de otros países
Entonces
es un país que exporta jugadoras que
también siempre van a estar en ritmo de
competencia y que además contrataron una
de las mejores directoras técnicas del
mundo que espía